- La mer, la plage,
les hôtels de luxe.
Principale statinénénénéaire
en Ukraine, Zatoka semble
à mille lieux de la guerre
qui secoue le pays.
Mais le calme n'est ici
qu'une acececece.
Et même à des centaines de
kilomètres de la ligne de front
personne n'est à l'abri.
Cet hôtel, frappé au
t t t t matin par un missile,
en est un bon exemple.
Elena et Vladimir habitent
à deux coins de rue.
Ils sont encore sous le choc."Nt
sourd qui a fait trembler
les murs et éclater les fenêtres
de tout le quartier",
explique-t-elle.
Les voisins ne comprennent pas
pourquoi l'hôtel a été frappé.
"On n'a jamais vu de soldats
ici; jamais vu le moindre
véhicule militaire",
jure-t-elle, convaincue
qu'il s'agit d'une erreur.
La voie de chemin de fer,
justtétététété, était peut-être
la cible réellement visée,
ou encore le pont situé
à quelques kilomètres.
Quoi qu'il en soit, cet hôtel
est le troisième du coin
bombardé en moins d'une semaine.
Encore un autre épisode absurde
dans une guerre qui paraît
insensée.
Aleksey non plus ne s'explique
pas cette folie.ririririririéta,
il en inspecte les ruines,
encore incrédule,
pour prendre la mesure de
l'étendue de la tragédie.
Une tragédie humaine,
d'abord et avant tout.
Car sous ces décombres
se trouvaient son fils, sa
belle-fille et sa petite fille.
"Aujourd'hui, ma famille a été
détruite, mon âme a été
piétinée, dit-il
et je ne sais pas pourquoi."
Submergé par l'émotion,
il doit prendre une pause
avant de raconter la suite.
Un récit qui s'écrit
dans le sang.
"Voilà la pantoufle de
ma petite-fille, raconte-t-il.
c c c c c c coincée ici
sous cette dalle.
Elle a perdu plusieurs doigts,
une main, et sa jambe ne tenait
que par la peau."
Alexandra n'a que 5 ans.
Elle est aujourd'hui
à l'hôpital, entre la vie
et la mort.
À la recherche de photos
pour mieux nous la
Aleksey se rend dans sa chambre.
Mais il ne trouve que les jouets
de la fillette, recouverts
de poussière, et la réalité
le s s s s s s s seul coup.
"Une minute, on regarde le ciel
bleu et la mer et on se dit
que la vie est bonne, dit-il.
Et la mi
on retrouve ses enfants
dans une mare de sang.
Et tout s'arrête."
"Je ne souhaite pas ça à
personne, ajoute-t-il.
Il faut absolument arrêter
cette guerre
Un cri du coeur, c
d'un grand-père inconsolable.
Seul élément positif dans
cette affaire, l'hôtel était
fermé au moment de l'impact,
fermé pour rénovation,
en attendant une éventuelle
réouverture ononononononononon.
Autrement, à en juger
par l'étendue des dommages,
le bilan aurait certainement été
beaucoup plus élevé.ananananana,
Radio-Canada, Zatok